first the new york post reports that
drive-ins are
thriving this year uh-huh that's right
an industry that had become just fun
nostalgia
is poised to continue and grow as a
business
even as the winter months bring the cold
weather many drive-ins are modernizing
online ticketing
ordering concessions like hot cocoa via
the app and in-car electric heaters so
you can save on gas
and in a year where having a sense of
community has been so tough
drive-ins have been a nice rediscovery
yes kicking it off
okay next up people magazine reports
that a study from the university of
rochester
found out that watching tv and movies
can
actually make your relationship stronger
it's not just netflix and chilling the
study found that couples who engaged in
conversation after watching a movie
or a tv show saw a 50 reduction in
divorce
compared to a control group it's the
conversation after watching that keeps
you together like
oh my gosh bruce willis was dead the
whole time
i love you honey no wonder you're not
fighting
you're zoning out to the boob tube all
day who's watching your kids by the way
oh you don't have them well you know
what's also good for relationships
anesthesia and starting
staring at a screen while not
communicating and bickering about daily
dilemmas so
yeah put on those horse blinders and a
muzzle and enjoy that relationship
here's one for all the gingers and
archies out there
today is national love your red hair
day two redheaded sisters created this
celebratory day as a way to celebrate
their hair and empower
their scarlet peers so let's give a
shout out to all our favorite redheads
prince harry looking splendid as always
lucille ball the og
yes my hero elizabeth the first
mmm yes sexy cartoon redhead jessica
rabbit
i'm not naughty i'm just drunk that way
ginger spice fun fact the only spice
girl that's actually a spice and my
personal
childhood icon pippi longstocking
she let me know i could do anything her
monkey's mr nielsen and her horse's old
man
her two best friends are tommy and
annika does anyone know pippi long
stocking
i love redheads so much i even went as
one for halloween
that's right we had the best halloween
you guys that was just amazing
all right and finally pop sugar reported
on a feline habit that all
cat owners are way too familiar with
it's when they stick their butts
in your face it turns out that experts
say this is the way your cat lets you
know she trusts you oh
evolutionarily it's a vulnerable area
and being in that position leaves her
exposed
literally so the next time that happens
just give your cat a loving scratch and
say gross
but i love you too all right